one problem 129 129 if N is a positive
integer is the value of B minus a at
least okay so it's a so n is positive
and positive integer and they're saying
is a value of B minus a at least twice
the value so that's greater than or
equal to twice the value of 3 to the N
minus 2 to the N and that's what we need
to test statement one tells us a is
equal to 2 to the n plus 1 and statement
and B this is still statement 1 is equal
to 3 to the n plus 1 so let's think
about this a little bit let's think
about this a little bit so let's
substitute this into this equation so
you get 3 to the n plus 1 3 to the n
plus 1 minus 2 to the n plus 1 is
greater than or equal to 1 let's
multiply this out 2 times 3 to the n
minus 2 times 2 to the N so what's 2
times 2 to the N well that's just 2 to
the n plus 1 right that's just 2 to 2
times 2 to the N is to the n plus 1
there's a minus sign there so that's
where I got it from so interesting just
like that we have a minus to the n plus
1 on both sides so we can just subtract
that from both side or add 2 to the n
plus 1 from both sides to cancel them
out so we get rid of that get rid of
that and then our statement boils down
to is 3 to the n plus 1 greater than or
equal to 2 times 3 to the N well we
could rewrite 3 to the n plus 1 as 3
times 3 to the N and we're testing
whether that's greater than 2 times 3 to
the N and they tell us that n is a
positive number but it actually doesn't
matter I mean because we have 3 to the N
on both sides and there's no way you can
even if you rose this to a negative
exponent you would still have a positive
number so you
divide both sides by 3 to the N and you
the statement rolls down to 3 is greater
than 2 which is absolutely correct so
statement 1 is enough information to
mate to say whether this statement is
true or not and actually proves that
it's true
let's look at statement number 2
statement number two tells us that n is
equal to 3 n is equal to 3 let's see if
we look at the original statement so if
n is equal to 3 then we have to say this
is this is what the statement reduces to
it reduces to B minus a is greater than
or equal to 2 times 3 to the third power
so that's 27 minus 2 to the third power
well 2/3 is 8 so it reduces to B minus a
is greater than or equal to 27 minus 8
is 19 times 2 is 38 well I don't know we
don't they don't tell us anything else
about B or a or anything so this is a
useless statement and actually going
through this was a little bit of a waste
of time you could have just said hey
you're talking about n is I can come up
with a number here but that still
doesn't give me any information over
what B or a is so statement 1 alone is
sufficient to answer this question and 2
is is not do some let me go to sky blue
problem 130 the inflation index for the
year 1989 relative to the year 1970 was
three point five six indicating that on
average for each dollar spent in 1970
for goods 356 had to be spent for the
same goods in 1989 let me write that
down
1970 one dollar in 1986 that same was
1989 they're talking about 1989 in that
same year in 1989 that same thing would
cost $3.59 Pharaoh 3 dollars and 56
cents I mean my sixes and nines confused
three dollars 56 had to be sent if the
price of a model came mixer increased
precisely according to the inflation
index what was the price of the mixer in
1970 so we want to know the mixer K
sir K in 1970 so statement number one
the price of the model K mixer was 102
point four dollars more in 1989 than
1970 so let's let's call this K we're
trying to figure out K 70 let's call
that's what we're trying to figure out
mixer K in 1970 so they say the price of
the model K mixer was a hundred two
dollars and 40 cents more in 1989 than
1970 so this essentially tells us that K
mixer K in 1989 - mixer K in 1970 is
equal to 102 dollars and 40 cents but we
also have other information we know that
mixer K it it went exactly with
inflation so the increase in inflation
price so we know that so mixer K in 1989
is equal to three point five six times
mixer K in 1970 well how do we know that
because they told us that mixer K the
price of it increased directly with this
inflation and anything that was $1
pretty much anything that went with
inflation was worth three point five six
times more in 1989 so mixer K in 89 is
three point five six times more than it
was in 1970 so now we have we have this
linear equation which was given in the
problem statement and we have this
linear equation so we have two equations
and two unknowns so we actually have
enough information just with statement
one to solve the problem and I'm
actually not even gonna go into it could
be a waste of time you should hopefully
we're getting into the rhythm of this
two linear equations two unknowns enough
information if they're quadratic or
something then you'd have to dig a
little bit deeper statement number two
or if they were somehow parallel
equations but I wouldn't worry that
about that too much on the GMAT
statement number two the price of the
model K mixer was one forty to forty in
1989 so they're telling us that K in
1989 was 142
40 well this is definitely enough
information because we already have this
equation that the 89 price which is 142
40 is equal to three point five six
times the 1970 price so you just divide
this by three point five six and you
have your answer so each statement
independently is enough to solve this
problem problem 131 is 5 to the K less
than a thousand so 5 to the K less than
a thousand statement number one tells us
that 5 to the k plus 1 is greater than
3000 I already know the census is going
to help us because it's essentially
setting a lower bound on 5 2 so let me
just explain it so 5 to the k plus 1
that's the same thing as 5 to the K
times 5 right so that's equal to 5 times
5 to the K right you could use this 5 to
the first power and then you would add
the exponents to get here and that they
say is greater than 3000 you divide both
sides by 5 and you get 5 to the K 5 to
the K that's a K is greater than 600
that doesn't help us 5 to the K could be
6,000 well 5 to the K could be 700 in
which case this would be true 5 to the K
could be 7000 in which case this
wouldn't be true so statement 1 by
itself isn't enough information
statement number two tells us 5 to the K
minus 1 is equal to 5 to the K minus 500
this is interesting so let's see if what
we can do here so this is the same thing
let's get all the k's on one side so the
same thing is 5 to the k minus 1 minus 5
to the k is equal to minus 5 is equal to
minus 500 and let's just say this is
well this is the same thing as 1/5 or 5
to the negative 1 let me write that 5 to
the negative 1
times 5 to the K and then minus 5 to the
K is equal to minus 500 let's factor 5
to the K out of this so you get 5 to the
K times 5 to the negative 1 that's 1/5
minus 1 right we factored a 5 to the K
out there is equal to minus 500 and
let's see what we can do 5 to the K 1/5
minus 1 that's minus 4/5 right times
minus 4/5 is equal to minus 500 and get
rid of the minus sign on both sides
multiply both sides by negative 1 and
then we can multiply both sides by 5 for
it so we get 5 to the K is equal to 500
times what 5 over 4 5 over 4 and that is
what that's 125 that's 5 let's see 2500
divided by 4 125
well you don't see 2,500 divided by 4 I
want to say it's 475 is that 5/4 no no
so each 4th is 125 and you have another
so it's equal to 625 even if I just got
my math wrong that doesn't matter
because they just want to know whether 5
to the K is less than a thousand and it
definitely is
even if my math 500 times 5/4 1/4 of 500
is 125 times 125 times 5 120 so we'll
have one more of those
all right 625 so statement 2 alone
statement 2 alone is sufficient to
answer the question statement 1 was kind
of useless I've run out of time see you
in the next video